ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we have a large
problem in this country people do not
want to work
um because of the stimulus
you see what happens people
do not want to work they don't need to
they don't need to come in and do their
jobs
so we're here because ben avery
has decided that he is part of some
labor movement uh because
he doesn't think he needs to work he
doesn't think he's treated well here
so he's decided to not show up
i talked to business owners all over
this country and they are telling me
they cannot get anyone to work
uh i i mean it's absolutely absurd
that these people will not do their jobs
they won't do them they just won't show
up
well look who it is
what what is what is this issue you're
having
i need to get paid in like real money
you're
you're paid in safe moon doesn't
i got bills i got a wife this show
barely makes any money
we don't have any money i can't pay you
any kind of money and stay afloat i just
saw that article that you
make a ton of money i had no idea the
media
is going to present things in any way
they want to you have a unique
opportunity here
well my landlord doesn't take safe
movement it's a uni it's a unique
opportunity you're building an
infrastructure
do you see what i mean and by building
an infrastructure
you then will one day sit behind the big
microphone
that's the goal
all right i just i'd like to get paid in
like not safe moon but well we'll talk
about it off there
i think safe moon is fun what about
light corn
that'd be fine you're going to work your
way up to ethereum
we don't start at ethereum but get some
of these statistics up
nobody is working and these are good
jobs like arby's
these aren't bad jobs these are good
jobs people aren't working at like
hardee's
who doesn't want to work at hardee's
and they they complain go to minimum
wage in america right now what is
minimum wage right now
i can't believe it
minimum wage i think it's it's and 25
cents per hour
what's the pro you're making 40 a day
what's the problem
do that what is on a 40 hour work week
725 is what
you will earn
a good living 290
a week
and ninety 290 a week that's almost 1200
for the month
what is that for a year if you're making
1200 for a month
you're looking at 14 15 000
that's what i thought what's the problem
out there
what's i don't get it do you get it
fifteen thousand dollars
per year because they don't understand
when they work at arby's they think it's
the end goal guys
if you play your cards right you move up
so that one day you can be the ceo of
arby's
that's the point good get the ceo of
arby's up who is this
i bet he started at orbeez
i it's paul brown
paul brown is the ceo what's his deal
let's look up paul brown
because i guarantee you this is a guy
that
started working the friars at rb's
putting the beef and chatters together
and then
he worked his way up
early career brown was previously the
president of brands
and commercial services at hilton
and the president of expedia but but
before this he worked at orbeez
i bet watch he was also the senior vice
president of global brands at
intercontinentals okay
but he also held positions at the boston
consulting
firm and mckinsey company now mckinsey
companies probably fast food
go to that this is probably a fast food
company
it's an american worldwide management
consulting firm oh
that advises on strategic management to
corporations governments and other
organizations
i thought it was like a what i'm saying
is that this is an example of someone
who worked their way up
from working at arby's
in may of 2013 brown became the ceo of
arby's
during his 10-year ceo of arby's the
brand introduced a new restaurant design
and launched so we have the meat he's
the guy behind we have the meat
no who could have came up with that
listen the reason these people are
making the money they are
is because they have come up with things
that you cannot
we have the meat do you remember that
campaign
because we were unsure if they had the
meats but they do
and he's here saying we have the meat he
also introduced menu items such as the
smokehouse brisket
pork belly gyros deep fried turkey and
venison
so he's not uh slacking
he's working his ass off okay
coming up with do you know how many
nights he probably laid in bed with his
wife or
and or someone else and he's laying
there going how do we
communicate the idea that we have the
meats
how do we do that and and and and some
hooker was probably just like we'll just
say you have the meats and he goes
yeah we have the meats
i'm telling you right now but arby's
completed its acquisition of buffalo
wild wings for 2.9 billion in 2018.
under brown's leadership inspire
completed its acquisition of sonic for
2.3 billion
and in 2019 of october inspire brands
uh completed its acquisition of the
sandwich chain jimmy johns
so this guy is responsible for a lot of
the fast food you eat
and he started work this is what i mean
people at arby's don't have a vision
they keep going oh my kid needs
food they don't have a vision they don't
understand like what they can do
if they believe in themselves and work
hard and hustle and grind
you can actually get to where you need
to go in this country you keep focusing
on
uh healthcare and i don't have clean
water but what you should be focusing on
is
what how are you positioned uniquely in
the market
to come up with something brilliant like
we have the meats
because if you're not coming up with we
have the meats what's the
point so i'm just saying we've got a
bunch of lazy
mothers and fathers trying to raise
their undeserving children
while this poor guy
paul who came up with the the idea that
we should give deep fried turkey to
people
in the middle of the day this guy has to
share some of his money
oh i think not by the way
under brown's leadership fortune named
arby's to its
100th best workplaces for millennials
women and diversity
so everyone who's [ __ ]
oh our east coast we're a perfect place
to work for everyone who's [ __ ]
are you a good place to work for white
men they go like this they go
no well i'm just saying
i i was surprised and shocked to to know
that this guy actually didn't start
making sandwiches at arby's i bet it's
fun to work at arby's i really do
i mean so the idea that people are
complaining
what about hearties ceo of parties let's
see
no just hardee's in general okay i want
to know what hardees is up to let's look
at hearties
see what they're up to what are they
doing
not in wikipedia i want their website
so then the a1 burger checkers just
introduced something called the monster
or something
i swear to god checkers go yeah checkers
new burger
i think it's checkers it could be
rallies or something
no the big buffer no that's been their
classic maybe it's rally it's something
i passed in florida it's called the
monster
something something i think that's
carl's jr
it might be carl's oh red robin no
no this is a fast food restaurant uh
that i passed i don't think it's that
it doesn't matter can we call arby's and
see if they're hiring right now
yeah i got mine's hooked up right now
let's call i want to call rbs
see if they're hiring and see what the
big deal is here
because i want to work and you know what
they might not even have to pay me
i just want to learn is there an
apprenticeship program where i can work
at arby's
and just learn how about that maybe stop
asking for money like him and
learn okay i'm calling arby's let's see
if they answer i hope they do
everyone's dead they can't answer
they're probably too busy to answer
learning
about business
i mean what the [ __ ] going on here and
these are the people that want to get
paid
i'm trying to get a job
maybe we should call inspire brands and
ask for paul
are they not open no they're open right
now they have to be open it's 12 30.
it's the lunch rush
whole sonic sonic okay call sonic and
let's see
what i want to know what the starting
salary is and what's the problem
sonic is a fun place to work you get to
see fights
it's fun
none of them to the phone
i mean good afternoon this is
me saying yeah are you guys hiring right
now
we actually are sir how are you doing
good what would this like starting
salary be there
the starting salary sir we pay by the
hour but depending on the position that
you want and then we can see about
salary
what would what would it be for an hour
of work would you say
yes sir uh how much would be for an hour
work
depends what you do sir if you're a cook
and it'll be 11 for a cook okay
11 for a cook what about like a cashier
uh we one has a cashier
carbs are five dollars an hour because
they get tips oh do you get a lot of
tips
they got a good amount tips but it's
just yeah they
they have a good amount of tips so it's
under minimum wage it's five dollars an
hour and then you get tips
yes sir is it a fun place to work like
can i take some food home
for myself yeah of course okay so i
could eat every day at sonic if i wanted
to
yeah he's got a yeah pretty much you
could have yeah drink all day drink
any drink you want any drink okay so
it's five dollars an hour but i could
drink all the soda i want
yeah okay and eat any food can i make
myself an ice cream every now and then
yeah of course yes sir it's not a bad
deal five an hour
tips do they really give you so they'll
give you tips and i can eat all the
uh soda and burgers i want and make
myself an ice cream
i mean you can make yourself an ice
cream and then maybe one day you'll be
able to make yourself ice cream and
another day you'll be able to you eat
some food and the other day
i get it so you don't want to abuse it
but every now and then you could get
something different
yes sir right so you have one day's ice
cream and then the next day you can
sneak a burger
yeah and he's maybe i could sneak some
french fries on the third day
yeah okay well i appreciate it man i'll
head down there and i'll apply
yes sir but yeah uh but cooks do get
paid 11
an hour and we already need crooks so
you're in need of cooks and do i have to
be good at cooking
no no not at all not really
you learned you don't need any
experience for this you just
gotta be having the willingness to learn
and then and how much food can the cooks
take i would say
probably a good amount uh what was that
sir
like the cooks can take a good amount of
food right
yeah we we cook about uh on the weekends
like from a thousand to two thousand
worth dollars worth of food and product
we're doing lunch and that's all right i
have a family
and it's very hard to get them food so
if i wanted to i could
maybe take two little burgers for my
children
yes i'll be fine okay yeah cause they
they're
they're one they're babies but they do
like burgers we're getting them
we're getting them started early yeah of
course they
all right well thank you very much for
your time brother i appreciate it yes
sir
thank you what's the problem i mean
what is the [ __ ] problem here
you're allowed to eat
and drink all the soda you want and eat
all the sonic you want
i but you got to do it in a smart way
it's like one day you make yourself the
ice cream the next day you get
and it's five an hour that
what's wrong with that it's five dollars
an hour
to work it's it now do the math on that
five dollars times four it's 800
a week right five times 40. it's 800 a
week
and then oh no it's 200 a week i'm an
idiot so then 800 a month
it's 800 a month is what i mean so 800 a
month so what's the pro
and now what is that it's under 12 grand
it's 11 grand a year
yes but then you get the tips but
but the folks you get the tips
now you know me i've got when i go to
sonic i didn't even know you could tip
or we're supposed to we've gone to sonic
there's literally nothing that would
suggest that i tip
at sonic not a sign i i don't but i
imagine that because you're making 9 600
a year
but free you could drink anything you
want any soda you want
one day you get an ice cream next day
you get french fries not a bad deal
if you're like me and my hypothetical
and i had two little babies
that wanted burgers if i was a chef i
could bring the little burger home
to the babies again it's not a big deal
so you make 9 600 for the year now this
is fair
you make 9 600 for the year but tips now
what do you think they make in tipster
20 000 25 000 it's sonic tips
how what do you think they're making
tips today honestly 25 bucks
a day yeah probably a day how many days
would you imagine they work
probably four four to five days so let's
say 525 is what
five times 25 would be 125. okay
and so 125 and then how many weeks let's
say
let's say they work 45 let's say they
work 50 weeks a year let's be honest
they probably work more so 50 times 125
okay
that's 62.50 add it to that nine
add it to the 9600
that is hey you greedy [ __ ]
that is 15 thousand eight hundred and
fifty dollars a year
to work all day every day
at st but what's included in that which
you're forgetting
you greedy pigs is an occasional ice
cream and probably you could make the
large
and all the soda you want
and and occasionally you can bring a
burger home for your baby
who you should get started on liking
that burger
as early as possible so it's absurd
it's really absurd the anger
do you understand what i'm saying do you
understand are you embarrassed now as an
employee complaining to me
a little bit have you ever paid for a
meal in your life never
and you're asking me for money to work
at this job do you not enjoy this job
i do and you're and you still come to me
and say i want actual money
and you and your wife want actual money
this is a bit better
more than he deserves truly and and and
and i i what i've done for him and his
wife is unimaginable what i've done for
everyone in my life is
is quite frankly unimaginable not my
family but most
most others really it's only been it's
really just ben but this
is a bit so don't in for in in in any
don't think that he
in any yeah i'm not leaving the show i'm
not
yeah and aren't you hap we do take care
of you very yeah yeah
okay don't start because people are so
dumb out there they don't know this is a
bit
but this is not a bit this is a fair win
you get 1500
thousand dollars a year because of the
tips it's sonic five
dollars an hour as a kiss sheer inside
wow and the tips aren't taxed because
that's cash
you know right well lucky ducks
you're a lucky duck i don't understand
the problem here
we've clearly showed that the ceo of
sonic
and and arby's and buffalo wings paul
brown
started as a fry cook
at mckinsey and company and worked his
way up
to intercontinental hotels and then
eventually hilton
and then inspire brands i like the name
inspire brands because it's inspiring
are these people not even grateful to
work for a company that's called inspire
brands so we had to do a little deep
dive a little investigating so we've
proven that the ceo is just self-made
from scratch guy who started on the line
making beef and chatters then we called
sonic
and we proved how fair it is because
there's a cookie make 11
and as a cashier you make five because
there's a little box
where people take their change and put
it in
after they've given you a five or a ten
dollar bill
so this whole idea that we're not fair
to workers in this country
is truly insane it's truly
truly truly truly insane now let's look
at paul brown's net worth
because i'm betting it's not that
goddamn much
i bet it's not that much
that's a lie that's an absolute lie
absolutely they're saying his net worth
it was 5.34 million that's an absolute
lie
that is by the way that is an that is an
absolute lie
oh hold on inspire supported by 650
company and franchise team members
the brand achieved 27 billion in global
system sales
yeah and paul paul paid 260. he's paid
and his net worth is only five point
three four million yeah okay
sure he's suffering
what about paul brown house yeah that's
like that we're not gonna say where it
is i'm just curious as to what he's
rocking out with
um let's see
it's gotta be something on images there
might not be
they keep him under wraps huh yeah well
he's broke
he's broke but this is what we mean here
it's
fair we don't understand the problem
ladies and gentlemen it's the summer
love blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in a chewable form at a fraction of
the cost last longer be harder
bluetooth is an online prescription
service no visit to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy and
it ships right to your door in the
discrete package
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
the best part is all done online
bluetooth licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient in strength for your
prescription don't like swallowing pills
no problem here blue chills sliding fall
and telephone
tablets are chewable they're made in the
usa and they prepare and ship direct
cheaper than a pharmacy so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform visit bluetooth.com for
more details
and important safety information and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code td at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth promo code td to
receive your first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
the spring is back as you get outdoors
to explore take bespoke posts on all
your adventures with a new lineup of
essential box of awesome this is so cool
whether you're taming the wilderness
or taking your home bar to the next new
level bespoke post only sends guys
the best stuff every month no matter
what you're into box of awesome has you
covered
this is a really cool thing a thing each
box costs 45 dollars but has 70 percent
of gear 70 dollars worth of gear inside
it's free to sign up you can skip a
month or cancel any time
it's really cool it's surprising if you
like getting gifts getting surprises
cool little things stuff that helps you
out be a dude
outdoorsy stuff booze stuff helping your
bar
style and grooming goods cooking tools
all that stuff
this is a cool thing to do it's better
than going to malls or spending
uh too much time online you might not
even know you want the things you
actually want
that's a box of awesome box of awesome
is perfect it curates
a box for you with all kinds of
different tools
and fun things for you to upgrade your
life we have a lot of young men
listening to the show middle-aged men
old man it's good for all of you
everybody can use a little upgrade
especially as we come out of quarantine
so get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
so you can basically help curate your
own box i'm telling you this is great
get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com and enter
the code tim dillon at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code tim
dillon for 20
off your first box a great way to
support the show and a really fun thing
i got a bespoke post box in the mail and
i love it it's really cool it's exciting
you got one
i got one too yeah yeah it's easy take
the quiz and what's really cool about it
is you can kind of help curate what goes
in there but they still surprise you
with a lot of cool stuff so i like
bespoke posts and so do you
chrissy teigen uh thrown off twitter
because she or not thrown off twitter
but being attacked by candace
by the way every time i see chrissy
teigen she looks different
right doesn't she look different every
time i see her
it's very interesting it's not
unappealing it's just different
she told courtney stodden to kill
herself
right yeah right here this is what
stoddan said
teagan would just publicly tweet about
wanting me to take a dirt nap but would
privately dm me and tell me to kill
myself
i gotta be honest like that's hilarious
stodden said
tegan would send her things like i can't
wait for you to die
tegan took to twitter to apologize i'm
mortified and sad who i used to be
i was an insecure attention-seeking
troll i'm ashamed to completely
embarrass at my behavior but that is
nothing compared to how i made courtney
feel
i have worked so hard to give you guys
joy but you haven't what has she ever
done
nothing you what did you what did you do
slap your name on some cookware
i work so hard to give you guys joy and
be beloved and the feeling of letting
you down is nearly unbearable truly
these were not my only mistakes it truly
won't be my last as i try hard
you know courtney stodden if we don't
know is what again
she's a singer she's a reality show per
what is
courtney stodd courtney so when she was
16 she married um
doug hutchinson the guy who plays percy
in the green mile
remember the guy who doesn't put the
sponge on uh
john coffey yes evil villain okay yes
and so he was uh courtney's acting coach
uh
via online back in the late 2000s and he
ended up marrying her when she was 16.
hey man weren't those the times so then
they made a reality show about them
being married when she was 16 and
uh they had a reality show about this
guy marrying a child yeah
there was a reality show called i'm
[ __ ]
my child
what was it called i think it was called
let me see
i i mean this is amazing to me is that
illegal to marry a 16 year old
uh well with the parents permission it
was okay oh well well
yeah well i imagine she came from a good
family good to know i was correct
yeah they appeared on couples therapy
couples therapy okay that was reality
show
because it's hard when you are dating
your daughter
now and i'm not one of these freaks that
thinks p i've dated younger people
doesn't matter i'm dating one now he's
younger but it's like
at least 16. let's draw a line here
let's draw a little bit of a line
anyway we have her song reality because
there's a really hot dude in this
it's kind of the nerd thing but this
came out in 2013.
this is courtney stodden's song reality
because
this is a very talented woman and i
think that
that gets lost in this let's take a look
at at her work
and by the way anybody at sonic
that's upset at where you are the
problem is you haven't attained this
level of talent do you get it
so if you're at arby's and you're angry
about the money you're making
how about you take a look at the
greatness and talent all around you in
this country
and it should no pun intended inspire
you
i give you courtney stardon's reality
she's good
[Music]
the moment
i better stop making burgers take a risk
[Music]
take a risk and be a genius
this is greatness
[Applause]
do you understand that's why you're not
making money because you're not
producing this context
[Music]
this is [ __ ] great
you don't need minimum wage you need a
little dose of reality
hi courtney stein
[Music]
this is almost so good that people are
going to be
put off because you're going to go i can
never do something like this
it's like listening to mozart
but this is what i mean about people in
this country
not realizing that this woman
is clearly a gift from from whatever you
want to call it
god or the universe i mean look at the
skill
let's play a little more of it
[Music]
you know what's good the writing
and he doesn't know what's happening he
thought he was going to be an actor
great vocal it's the way she the way she
sings
it's amazing and i like the candy in the
background
because what that's saying is candy and
i'm candy
it's this whole thing is about
colonialism
but you're not getting that this is
about
well she's sucking his cocktails
that's what that is about you have to
read into it
it's not cheap this is about
colonialism and how to decolonize
this is when it gets wild look at yeah
[Music]
this is about the right of return
i'm telling you people don't get it this
is one of the most brilliant things ever
done
why would you tell this woman to kill
herself when she's doing this kind of
art christie by the way what's ironic is
if chrissy teigen had a music v
it would be this yes like that's ironic
is like
it would just be chrissy teigen with
cookware and her husband playing piano
in the back it would be
chrissy teigen and this woman have the
same level of talent which is why they
don't like each other that's why
christine is threatened by her because
you are her
chrissy teigen is this woman by the way
chrissy keegan has
zero zero going on zero skills
zero zero zero she's a zero when people
are like
she's a static pedophile and eating
people i'm like no those people have
jobs like she's less
she can't eat any she's she's a [ __ ]
a complete drain on earth
let's just finish this we've gone so far
i got to see the ending
but that's why chrissy doesn't like her
[Music]
i like that she goes down on him in the
video it's good it's good for
people to see for the children
i mean anyone not recognizing the deep
themes
present here is just completely
willfully ignorant
of the message
at the end she just goes free palestine
anyway that's courtney stott and i hope
they patch it because
i like when talented people get along i
do
i can't believe this people are mad at
barry weiss
again barry weiss
uh people are angry with her
because she uh wrote something
um where you gotta go on twitter she
wrote
uh something she's trying to get
pregnant by the way okay
with her uh uh partner nelly and and
it's been difficult for her and do you
know why it's it's been difficult
it's been difficult for her she's trying
to get pregnant with a bomb
so it's very it's very hard because they
keep wanting her to have a human baby
but she keeps she said it'd be more
she'd be more comfortable with the
missile
so that's it's been very difficult for
her now
it's been hard now she and she did say
it's very tiring
to get pregnant while advocating a
genocide it's very
trying so she wrote something where she
was basically like hey
uh zionism every now and then we gotta
just uh
go in there and she has a quote it's
pretty disturbing
okay where it's basically like uh i
don't know if she
meant to say this but it does come off
negative
quote the results of this message always
are especially bad for the palestinians
who live under hamas rule
hamas rule casualty reports are hard to
verify because hamas controls the media
even the international press
inside the gaza strip but it appears
that more than 50 palestinians have been
killed
here's what people are upset about this
quote some of these people are entirely
innocent non-combatants including
children this is an unspeakable tragedy
it is also one of the unavoidable
burdens of political power and
power of zionism's dream turned into the
reality of self-determination
well that's not great what she's saying
is that the dead children
and the innocent people that have died
are an unavoidable burden of political
power of zionism's dream
turned into the reality of
self-determination it's a little callous
it's a little callus for someone who's
trying to get pregnant right
as a little callus when are we doing her
podcast
the ninth we'll be free that day
probably what we love is getting booked
on things and then seeing if we can free
up our day so we can go have lunch
and i have no issue with barry outside
of some of the crazier things she said
i understand people make her out to be
like some ghoul this isn't helping that
but i mean she has said some things that
make sense this one i don't know makes
sense
it's very strange to be uh picking out
furniture for nursery
and then also say hey every now and then
uh zionism's gotta come in and uh get
kill the babies
that's a tough you know it's just ironic
she's
actually like trying to get pregnant
during this
time you know it's almost like she says
to the doctor she goes and don't worry
if my child acts up and goes against
israel i will also
realize that they must be killed because
it is one of the burdens of political
power
the doctor's like uh okay
all right thanks for coming in it's
getting wild over there
i i you know israel netanyahu's taking
that country in a very like
right-wing crazy thing also
the other side is that people think
hamas is like a theater group that's
also not true
so i'm just an irish catholic from long
island really leave me alone i just
don't care anymore
i know you're going to get mad at me for
saying that i know you're going to
listen i think what you the palestinians
should not live in those conditions
that's ridiculous
um but the real people who are suffering
right now
truly i mean yes yes
the people over there but truly it's the
people that are going out for their
first lunches and brunches
that have to deal with this horse [ __ ]
and i'm going to provide a way
for you to get out of talking about this
while you're out at your first lunch
the post-quarantine lunch these are
things that i've seen my father do his
entire life
and they really they really do help
start we're at a lunch right now start a
conversation about israel and palestine
uh did you see the israeli strike
destroyed the gaza knight
with very sad not good
not good it's uh a mess
you got a mess yeah the al jazeera
building it's uh
oh boy you got these ones and then those
guy
i mean and forever it's been going on
forever
it's bad yeah the u.s said this is
social crab out of season
i think it is it it's it's out of season
in the spring
but that's all right i love the grouper
but
stick to it's bad it's a mess
what a long time i can't believe it
i just want peace just say that guy just
i just want peace
i hope they figure it out i hope they
figure it out i just want peace
then steer the conversation into a fish
dip because
there's nothing you can do all these
people that are tweeting and
i understand that but there's nothing
you could really do
uh there's probably quite a blackmail
operation going on
that the massage has been doing for a
little while that's right joe biden i
mean
these people really can't say anything i
mean this is a guy that what made out
with 11 year olds what does he have to
hide
and so you get to a point where you go
yeah we're kind of
you know all of our political leaders
for the most part are are kind of
blackmailed
and then you have people like ilhan omar
who thinks that uh
you know we should just the white guys
have to go into camps so it really isn't
it's there's no way out so what you just
do
is try to avoid the conversation uh
because politics uh can really ruin
what is a lovely lunch
that's what it is it's time to get out
of your post-quarantine
relationships if you were in a
relationship with somebody i don't mean
if you met in the last couple of months
but i mean
if you were in a relationship with
somebody when they shut down the nba
it's time to call it quits
out leave your wife um
leave your husband get out get out now
because it's over say it was very fun
wearing masks with you
but it's time to go and this is awkward
people are watching this their bed right
now smoke on a joint
you know the end is nigh you know it
you know come july you are going to be
you are going to be out of there
i mean just window open and [ __ ]
sheet tied down as a rope climbed out
out done
this includes even some friendships like
you got to shake it up
keep moving the quarantine was a very
interesting time for a lot of people
but you got to go now you can't
keep beating the dead horse these
relationships a lot of them were trauma
bonding you got to just get out
reconnect later maybe not no
don't maybe i don't know but i'm telling
you a lot of relationships
i'm seeing them myself i go and also
move move you're not going to want to
live where you quarantined you just go
somewhere else for a year
you know rehabilitate yourself
get somewhere else in your own life and
then go back i'm telling you right now
leave your wife and kids right now leave
your husband and children
destroy your family it's time
this year's about you
it's about you it's not about the others
this is a year of selfish hedonism
it's a year of disgusting libertarian
values
it's a year of horrible things
anti-society behavior just
glorifying every impulse eating s'mores
out of a stranger's [ __ ] in a subway
platform that's what this year's about
it's not about anything else don't miss
it
you're gonna have to do it i'm telling
you i know it's
hard to look at someone you went through
this whole thing with them and it's like
you guys are like yeah you know and
you're like should i propose
the answer is no you have to go out
experience other things are you and your
wife gonna break up
no we're happily together but then you
knew each other before the quarantine
yes a long time that's why it works
but if you had met during the quarter i
mean it's just
you gotta go and this is why israel and
palestine are having issues
in my estimation truly
i don't think there were problems before
this
i don't know if there were but i haven't
read about them
this is a cuffing season quarantine like
okay we wore masks together we watched
the news together we figured out who
anthony foucher was
and now you have israel who's like more
powerful in the relationship but you
have palestine who's like a dirty
freaking bed
and then you have these two people and
now they're just not seeing eye to eye
they have to like
amicably break up do you understand
because
kwar is over and is and pal
have to go but they can't bother their
friend tim
who's just on the other side of the
world finally
mask off enjoying a lunch i don't have
to have talking points about this
i don't have to go through talking
points i this is the summer of no
talking points telling you right now the
summer of no opinions
oh your mother's a rape to your sister
yeah
all right the summer of no opinions
you just had four years of opinions what
did that do nothing
the summer of no opinions the summer of
yeah man don't know if it's not fun not
doing it
it's got to be fun water park build a
fort
try drugs again maybe you can handle
them this time
boost it up drink and drive a little not
a lot but if you have three
four in you and i mean cocktails not
beers always get in a car with three or
four beers [ __ ]
but i mean if you if you're feeling it
or you got four cocktails
and it's a late afternoon and you're not
gonna get popped get in there and feel
what it feels like
to control a vehicle drunk
light a butt blast so lonely by the
police
this is that summer this isn't a summer
about making documentary films
this is a summer about letting it go a
little bit
having a little fun fly somewhere to
suck someone off
buy a plane ticket to suck someone's
[ __ ]
and have them give you a whatever a
return
[ __ ] but that's what this summer's
going to be about
and this is really starting to ruin it
and i don't want to see that i want to
see
people being happy on the beach remember
quarantine was so [ __ ] up but now
we're happy
because we can make 15 000 a year at
sonic
and everyone is going to be out this
summer and i mean everyone
so you got to pick and choose your
places it's going to be a little
grotesque out there
the tits are out the fat puss is going
to be out you're going to be
you're just going to have a fat [ __ ]
put right on your table as you're
reaching for a handful of calamari
it's going to be a wild summer you got
to get ready wet and wild
bad bad disgusting people just vomiting
puking oding left and right
giving birth on the middle of a dance
floor that's where we're headed to
it's gonna get [ __ ] nuts masks off
tits out people living on borrowed money
and borrowed time
you're gonna be getting stimulus [ __ ]
do it don't waste this summer in long
meaningless conversations in brooklyn
with some other loser and a knit sweater
but actually but i really think shut up
let's [ __ ] what are we doing
life is too short take this pill
let's kill someone together let's murder
my mother
that's what this summer's about
courtney stodden people like her
geniuses what do you think about israel
and palestine i i think i stand with
palestine
wow you know what that would have been
harder for us to say but
they just passed on our movie
[Laughter]
and you know who didn't pass on our
movie hamas
so that's what happens we just fine we
don't want to be in the industry anyway
you know
so great it would have been nice to have
a film but what are you going to do what
are you going to do
who cares we're having enough fun here
but that's my advice for this summer
check out find some new people enjoy
some things
travel in make your life meaningful this
summer
in any way that you can if you can i
know it's hard out there
the whole uh first half of the show we
showed you how [ __ ] people are we're
not blind to that
but i'm saying even in any little small
way that you can
get away from the people that you spent
just quarantined with it is essential
it is really essential that you leave uh
because i think you want to have a
little bit of an adventure
and this quarantine was kind of a weird
inverted adventure
where it was like a slumber party uh for
a year
and everybody who's in their pajamas and
you can't go out now
we're we're heading back out and we're
going to come out in the world very
sloppily
you know you ever see like a horse like
a baby horse
where after it's give birth it can like
barely walk and it's covered in like
after birth
that's what people are gonna look like
walking into clubs and restaurants just
covering after birth not even able to
walk just
being led to their seat that's what's
gonna happen but you have to
embrace that just for the summer and
then in the fall get serious
get serious but this summer you should
be having sweaty
uh sex with people that you don't know
even if you're not gay you should be
having gay
sex you should bring another man into
bed with you and your wife
a man of color here's something new you
know the price of gold has been all over
the place lately now there's a new way
to buy gold through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house and just recently
acre has introduced a new hundred dollar
a month subscription to a 5g
gold bar acre lets you invest in
physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once
as inflation goes crazy you're going to
watch this become
more and more essential acre keeps you
updated on your gold stash every month
and ships once you reach the price
threshold with acre taking physical
delivery of your gold means it's safe
and sound in your hands
acre ships your gold directly and
discreetly to your door acre designs are
gold in california and sources they're
gold from one of the largest mints
in switzerland it's actually really
interesting because acre gold
is one of the very few affordable
tangible things you can buy
that will be worth anything in five
years think about it
that part is mind-blowing but the big
takeaway here is that you don't have to
come out of pocket all at once to
acquire
meaningful gold over time anybody that
knows anything about investments has a
certain percentage
of their portfolio and precious metals
specifically gold it's true
visit getacregold.com tim dillon that's
getacregold.com
tim dilling start investing in physical
gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for that giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre again
that's
getachergold.com t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
tim dillon thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
this is something that we're gonna start
doing let's start putting a little money
in gold
it's a great hedge against inflation it
always has been historically
and this is a great way to do it the
companies that advertise this show are
either a great product
that i love or a gang of money and
usually both to be working with me
and this one in particular is a fan of
my comedy
sheath underwear dot com boy do i love
sheath it has a pillow case for your
junk
it's a pillow it's beautiful they are
the best you have to try it for yourself
you got to give them a google sheath
underwear.com
do some research the inventor robert
patron
check the story it's interesting and
even somewhat uh
inspiring and i don't know if you know
the story
of robert patron who is the the leader
of
sheath underwear
the guy who invented sheath underwear he
is the first
openly gay person
to be court-martialed for war crimes in
the united states military
it is an inspiring story
about an openly gay kind of marquis de
sade type
who just uh participated in the routine
brutal murder and torture of women and
children
but it's also he was openly gay so it's
like everyone
contains multitudes sheath underwear dot
com use code
tim to save 20 until christmas sheath
underwear dot com we do love it we use
this great as a bathing suit too
sheath underwear dot com use code tim to
save 20
till christmas and support this openly
gay psychotic mass
murderer sheath underwear dot com promo
code tim
look at this now the nypd they're not
letting march in the gay pride parade
they're not letting the nypd and
this is a real punishment for them
because
that's their favorite thing to do is
march in the gay pride parade
the nypd interesting
heritage of pride the non-profit
organization that produces new york's
famous
pride parade announced saturday it's
banning corrections and law enforcement
exhibitors
from participating in nyc pride events
until 2025.
nypd is not required to lead first
response and security at
nyc pride events all aspects of first
response and security
can be reallocated to train private
security community leaders and
volunteers
i think if they want to punish the cops
make them all march
go every sing turn it into a cop march
take all the police and make them wear
revealing clothing and
they should all every nypd officer
you should have to walk down the street
with a sign that says i am gay
we are all gay if anyone is gay i am gay
that's what the shirt should read they
should have pink shirts that say if
anyone is trans i am trans i am gay
and they should all have to march and
they should have choreographed dance
numbers
that would be [ __ ] good i mean they
don't care about this
no this is absurd what a crazy thing
it's a weird way to punish the police
what's next wait i mean i mean what's
next are you gonna
are you gonna ban them from attending
broadway shows
are you gonna ban them from the opera
what comes next now
are the cops not going to be allowed to
go to the ballet
i mean this is terrifying for the police
on friday the nypd gay officers action
league
hilarious name the gay officers actually
released a statement saying they were
disheartened by the decision
to placate some of the activists in our
community
they're looking to create a safer space
for the lgbtqia
and bipoc bypoc
that is
i know the last one's people of color uh
black indigenous black
indigenous people of color communities
at a time when violence against
marginalized groups
specifically bypack and trans community
has continued to escalate the sense of
safety that law enforcement is meant to
provide can instead be threatening
and at times dangerous to those in our
community who are most
often targeted with excessive force and
or without reason
is this the new thing now cops are
killing gays
i know i know that during the stonewall
riots the cops were clearly
uh uh you know behaving like murderous
fascists
and i know that they do that too often
but is that the thing where it's like uh
cops are uh
out there with uh gays i don't know i
mean i haven't heard that
but i i imagine that is a new
uh that's a new
thing here let's also before we leave
let's
comment on this um tony hinchcliffe
our friend uh and i've been on kill tony
many times
got himself into a little bit of a
pickle he
made a statement he's as a joke
he was saying something about the host
of a show and he called him a filthy
[ __ ]
something uh he's an asian gentleman
he's only really two or three but you're
gonna it was the
it was was not good it's the one that
lands not good
tony i do not believe is a hateful
person i don't believe he hates people i
don't believe he's racist
i believe he made and i said this on
twitter the worst decision of comic or
human anybody in that
particular moment can make in that time
that was not a good choice and people
got enraged about it angry about a
tony's a rose comic
what tony does uh is roast people now
outside of the show kill tony
that uh can be harrowing i guess that's
you know if you don't know tony as a
roast comic and you're not
in his element watching what he does and
how he does it
uh it can be uh disturbing and people
were obviously
uh unhappy with it that being said i
will say personally about tony
a lot of people have launched their
careers on kill tony black people
uh gay people he's helped me
dramatically he's helped other people
trans comics
there's a lot of people that have
traveled for hours and they've flown
states to go to kill tony for the chance
to do their set
and to get roasted by tony and to rose
tony um
you know he has guys with als michael
lehrer who's a brilliant comic with als
he has him on the show every week tony
does have a heart he's a human being
um and i think that reducing him to just
this collection of words
is unfortunate and they were the wrong
collection of words it was the wrong
thing to do it wasn't funny
it didn't work that being said to
diminish him as a human being because of
this
is a little ridiculous and of course we
all know what happens the agencies drop
them and this happens and that happens
and this is what uh
happens you know and to me knowing him
and knowing that
he has provided a platform he built
something and it's still a show and i'm
you know on twitter i said it meant
something to people and i talked to him
he's like you're staying at the past and
i'm like i know but right now it's
you know but it'll be back but i'm
saying that like the show meant
something to people of all races genders
sexual orientations you can't just
diminish that and i know that
you know there's a lot and i didn't you
know the full sets i think provide a
little bit more context still it was
probably
not the best uh choice to make
in that moment but that's what being a
comedian is
you do make choices some of them are
good some of them are bad
um and it's hard you know seeing that
it's hard to see
where the funny would have been right
but a lot of people
will say things and then look back at it
and go ugh not
great you know me being one of them i
mean i've said all kinds of things
now usually everything i say is correct
and that's another burden
that i have the burden of being right
all the time about everything
which people don't think that's a burden
it's a terrible burden
where's my netflix special i'm right all
the time
and they don't like that okay
also stop talking about john mulaney and
his olivia munn leave him alone who
gives a [ __ ]
he stopped doing blow and he needs some
strange let him be
let him be the bad people in this
business are the ones who use words
people don't like
not the people who destroy their
families
[Music]
anyway those are the bad people don't
you get it
see you can do anything to anyone in
your personal life
as long as you say the right things do
you see what i mean
you never try and i'm not a moralist i'm
not saying to judge anyone morally for
their personal life
but what happens is in your personal
life you can do whatever you want
kids on the island in the cage [ __ ] it
who cares
come here honey doesn't matter as long
as you get out and you
say what is needed
at the moment it's needed it doesn't
matter
what you behave like in fact it almost
feels like i don't know it almost
feels like saying this
[ __ ] that they want you to say
can inoculate you to a certain degree
from being judged in any other way
i'm sure that's not the case i'm sure
i'm wrong
but making life about words and
phrases and opinions and not making
it about character and what people do
and if you're an entertainment i think
it should be about
nothing i don't care if you're funny or
funny melanie's a genius
whatever you think about whatever he's
he's a comedic
like you know he's not my favorite
comedian but when i watch john mulaney i
go that guy is [ __ ] amazing
at this that's a fact and if you don't
think so
and and when i watched nicole i say
similar things like
it so yeah i mean the family is involved
in some
but who cares you know at the end of the
day to me
it truly is what you're doing on the
stage but what's interesting to me
is when everything becomes about words
and just
i have the right opinion in the right
package and that's good and
that's odd it's very interesting to me
that that's really what people care
about
hollywood is riddled with divorce with
abuse
uh with all kinds of problems as is
america
and uh but there's a real obsession with
having the right
posture on the right issues
and that's what it seems to be so
talking about this you have to realize
that
i've seen tony personally help people
of every race by giving them a platform
on a show by encouraging them after the
show
by having them open for them by doing
certain things by putting them
so the idea that you can reduce this guy
to just a
sentence that he said which was again
not wise
but you you could reduce him to that
after he's had a career of doing this
whether you like his comedy or not the
show that he built means something to
people
and it has elevated people uh and it has
elevated them in cases where the
industry has not elevated them
and he's given a pathway for people to
earn money
uh blah blah blah so that's what it is
and that's that's what i have to say
about i did want to address it i know
other people will not be addressing it
of course
because they don't have platforms as
large as mine so
we will just say that um
you know and and that's what i'm saying
people need to be able
to be taken uh
the whole of what they've done has to be
judged not a few things here and a few
things there
who people are uh if you're going to
judge them you should judge them
on uh everything not so much just one
thing
so it is unfortunate
but we do have a new ad that i just got
on my phone and i want to read that
because obviously we got to make money
on this show
and half of my thing is out now like
it's this year but it's not this year
right but he wants more money and give
him more money
okay let me read this ad because
i said just got this emailed to me
now that quarantine is lifting people
are feeling like they have the
revolutionary spirit all pent up in them
that's why
hamas is proud to sponsor the tim dillon
show hamas is a palestinian sunni
islamic fundamentalist organization
but it has a pragmatic and militant
track record of advancing nationalism
hamas come on down
we are proud to have them as a sponsor
of the tim dylan show a lot of people
said don't take that ad but they paid
go back to england prince harry people
are mad at harry because uh he doesn't
understand the first amendment is there
any more proof that this guy's a fame
hungry grifter
him and his wife literally uh are coming
here
the american media is bamboozled by them
i've got so much to say about the first
amendment i still don't understand it
but it is bonkers
it's bonkers if if somebody has a first
amendment they might say something a lot
more family killed my mother
man why is harry here
why is he here they're here because
they're getting in bed with netflix
they're getting in bed with everybody
this is what they're going to do um they
want to be celebrities they were sick of
being lizards
so they want to be celebrities they
double crossed their lizard family they
don't have the decency to go to the
bloodletting rituals
they're here trying to [ __ ] uh you
know cry on oprah and have a netflix
series i mean
how disgusting truly what's more
offensive
being a [ __ ] interdimensional
shape-shifting lizard
or whatever [ __ ] these two have now
become
strutting around hollywood trying to get
streamers to make their garbage content
get the [ __ ] out you white devil
get out of our country you pale white
ginger [ __ ]
out go i don't like the first amendment
they let people say whatever they want
here that's when the the [ __ ] the the
prince comes back out
i try to be like every man joe rogan
don't talk about the vaccine but then he
goes why do they have the first
amendment
here why do they have it this guy has no
core
he has no [ __ ] soul look at his face
look at the vacant face of that guy
do you know how scary it is to be at
that [ __ ] point in your life and not
have a goddamn clue
as to who you are he has no [ __ ] clue
so this [ __ ] came in bamboozled him
pussy-whipped him dragged him back to
america but he's a willing participant
in this
by the way and they're trying to be
jay-z and beyonce except slightly
reversed
whatever it is get him out of here but
look at the vacant look in his eyes
he doesn't exist he has no core he is
dangerous
that is a dangerous man a man without a
core a man who has no
idea who is oh what is his first
amendment i've read about
it but it's weird you've never read
about the
cornerstone of our country you dumb [ __ ]
what is this first amendment
why does tim dillon get to talk i don't
like it
me and megan are making a documentary
about people with cleft palates
and netflix has bought that we don't
want any more comedy specials with the
first amendment
we want a documentary of people with
cleft palates
that's my favorite thing to watch is
little kids with cleft palates smile
and make sandcastles god
he's grotesque he is a grotesque
human being and he must go truly
uh i mean truly truly truly
we are launching merch it is coming on 5
20. it is a new fake business collection
nelk can't win this game we must
now advance we will now nelk is lovely
to me and they send me free stuff they
send me
free merch um but we will not be sending
them free merch
that's right mr we'll do it if you want
the merch you will do it
yourself but this is coming 5 20
go to what fakebase.net fakebiz.net
and sign up you put your email they give
you a quick email
when this goes live it is going live on
5 20 which is what day
thursday and this does not end with a
merge drive we're opening stores in
paris and london in milan
fifth avenue in new york we're going
global this is a global
fashion brand
that's what it is get on board now
go to fake biz biz.netfakebiz.net put
your email in
to be alerted we've got a new can we
show them let's play our video
let's show them what we got we're
bringing the heat
these are legitimately beautiful clothes
this is not what we did last time which
was good
the screen printing was good we've taken
it up to the next level we've kicked it
up
another notch as they say let us watch
this promo together
cut together by uh ben avery who wants
more money for him and his wife
i do fake business i call up realtors
all day when i'm bored
and i pretend
[Music]
as for me i like the stock kings of leon
yeah
they tell us we're the first to release
our album uh as an nfc
you know that lindsay lohan now has a
non-fungible token
i wonder if like rockefeller and
carnegie and vanderbilt came back i
wonder how disgusted they'd be at the
new crop of people
that have taken their place the currency
that was invented as a joke
in fact becomes the real currency to the
[Music]
moon
fake biz.net
get on there put your email in
very exciting times coming up very
exciting things we're on the road there
might be some tickets left for foxwoods
uh we're in san antonio we are all over
the place
i am in san antonio texas denver if it's
not all sold out try
raleigh north carolina july 9th and 10th
at the wilbur theater in boston which is
almost all sold out but go give it a
shot the 21st through the 23rd
foxwoods casino on the 24th irvine
california the 29th to the 31st
chicago illinois august 24th through the
28th we are out there
having fun doing stuff i'll be in la
this week all over the place running
around
doing spots if you're there come say
hello
merch is in the store
fine do you want you want to be paid
actual money
yeah okay fine
see your first your first check will be
coming
okay of actual money okay okay
i'll believe it when i see it well what
i'm just saying is
you have all the opportunities in the
world
and to want money is so crass
it's so crass and undignified to even
talk about money
to want money or to even talk about
money to me is crass and undignified
and i don't know why you and the other
people are in this country the workers
are doing it
why would you not realize the unique
opportunity that you have
at arby's why would you not
realize the how lucky you are
to be at arby's like paul brown who
started there
and worked his way up to be the ceo
that's what it is you can't we're
talking about the wrong things here
so just remember i get annoyed when it
takes a little bit longer to get a
fillet of fish but just remember that
you know i listen man people these
companies got to start paying people
actual money
that doesn't mean everyone will want to
work when there is actual money either
by the way
but they do have to start uh raising
wages to lure people back to the market
it's already happening and that's a good
thing that's a good
thing truly i don't think it's a bad
thing to put a little pressure on
companies so that they have to pay
people more money
that doesn't mean this doesn't hurt
small businesses or people like that
if they can't find work and they can't
find people to work there
but um you know we got to figure out
something where people in this country
can live
because it is quite difficult right now
uh to live on the wages that
we have shown that people are making i
mean this is poverty level wages
this is completely completely ridiculous
so i think that people are gonna have to
start
um you know paying paying real money
you know to other people because
it's tough out there and we and we hope
uh we wish that israel and palestine
figure it out
that's all i can say we wish that israel
and palestine
figure it out that barry weiss figures
it out
hopefully she finally gets pregnant um
you know in nine months when she gives
birth to a missile
it flies out of her [ __ ] and kills only
a military target
goodbye